En fait le costume d'Aliénor, que je suis
en train de mettre au fur et à mesure
(c'est bien ça ensuite ? Oui.) c'est le costume
de Lady Marianne dans Robin des Bois.
(c'est à l'envers)
Le film Robin des Bois, de Ridley Scott, qui
est sorti vers 2012, quelque chose comme ça.
Historiquement il était pas terrible, l'armure
ajustée de Lady Marianne à la fin est un
petit peu WTF, mais j'avais bien aimé certains
costumes.
Déjà j'ai bien aimé le film en lui-même,
les musiques étaient géniales.
Ce costume est galère !
Il est très galère à mettre parce qu'il
y a trois couches.
C'est chiant.
Et pour l'enlever, j'suis obligée de me contorsionner
comme pas possible.
Eh, en plus y'a des épingles.
Bref, à la base j'avais fait ce costume parce
que je fais du cosplay aussi, j'ai déjà
dû le dire sur Twitter ou quelque chose comme
ça.
C'est la reproduction de costumes tirés de
fiction, beaucoup en font avec des costumes
de mangas et moi c'est plutôt avec des costumes
de films, de jeux vidéos...
(Troisième couche).
Et donc, le costume de Lady Marianne est un
costume qui n'est même pas d'époque, en
fait, parce que le film est censé se passer
vers le XIIe siècle il me semble, et ça,
on m'a dit que c'était un costume plutôt
XVe.
Donc bref, rien à voir, mais je l'avais fait
parce que je le trouvais joli.
C'est un costume qu'elle porte quand elle
laboure les champs.
Rien de glamour !
Et l'autre costume un peu rose que je portais
cet été, qui était plus léger, c'est le
costume d'Azénor, l'une des maîtresses du
roi Arthur dans Kaamelott.
J'avais fait un groupe Kaamelott pour Japan
Expo, qui était super marrant.
Et donc j'avais fait une des maîtresses du
roi Arthur, parce que tous les personnages
cools étaient déjà pris donc j'ai fait
la maîtresse kleptomane qu'on ne voit que
dans un épisode.
Mais c'est pas grave, c'était marrant.
On avait eu plein de prix en plus, on s'était
bien éclatés avec la prestation et avec
le groupe, on avait un Perceval, plein de
trucs...
Voilà, ben on va tourner la suite maintenant,
ça se fera pas tout seul.
Voilà ! C'était le petit aparté.